hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book nineteen
as st. Augustine is taking up and
incorporating some of the key ideas from
ancient philosophy into a Christian
theological framework one of the issues
that he's going to consider and it's a
very complex issue is our social nature
as human beings and you can translate
these terms as social or political
socialists coming from from Latin and
political is coming from Greek Poli TK's
right and both of these refer to our
tendency as human beings to relate
ourselves to other human beings to exist
not just simply as to use Aristotle's
metaphor and isolated you know peace and
in a checkerboard or a chessboard but
rather as part of a whole matrix of
relationships and Augustine wants to
make a point here about the complex
nature of our social existence which is
we are in fact social creatures and we
can't realize our fundamental good
without taking that into consideration
but in this existence in this world
on this side you might say if the Great
Divide separating us off from eternity
we can't fully realize that and social
life itself is beset with all sorts of
problems and conundrums and oftentimes
in trying to solve one of them we
actually make things worse
so he'll discuss this in terms of four
circles and you could think of these as
wider and wider and wider concentric
circles and this is not a radically new
idea in fact you see the Stoics talking
about this very notion extending from
the family all the way out to the world
of human beings taking all of us into
consideration there's a certain
cosmopolitanism involved and then even
talking about a common wealth of human
beings and gods of the human and divine
of all rational creatures so Augustine
is working with a blueprint that's
already there but he's looking at this
now in terms of the culture of his time
and how we can place this into a
Christian framework so he tells us that
that human beings whether we're talking
about the city of man or the City of God
are indeed social creatures and he talks
here about the whys we might talk about
philosophers in that sense although a
lot of philosophers are actually not
quite quite that wise and we can talk
about the Saints meaning the holy people
the people that are in touch with and in
communion with or a connection with the
divine and he says that in the City of
God people be will be social beings so
it's not as if heaven is going to be
your own little place over there all by
yourself no it would be a community that
would be unlike the other communities
that you've experienced in that it would
be lacking discord or rather you could
say that it would totally enjoy Concord
peace
however you want to frame it in this
life however we experience things very
very differently we only get a foretaste
of what it would be like to have
everybody on the same page without
requiring everybody to be in lockstep
with each other you might say and so we
experience as he's going to say a lot of
evils in social life and this is what
makes it so tragic for us as human
beings we have this innate desire it's
part of our very nature to want to be
connected with other people even the
misanthrope who says that they hate
everybody else and can't stand it's
usually because they've been
disappointed it's usually because
they've been hurt and they haven't
processed it well and all of us crave
some sort of connection with others and
larger and larger ways of organizing
human society and yet it's usually
screwed up in one way or another so
Augustine is going to talk about four
different circles here and let's talk
about very briefly what they are and
then we'll look at each one of them we
have as the smallest one the family or
the household and this would also
include friendships here we're talking
about people that we definitely know
we're intimate with we are connected
with quite frequently through various
chants you know you don't choose who
your parents are gonna be nor do you
choose your cousins and this is how many
of us exist in fact most of us are still
raised in one way or another in families
and even if we don't stay connected with
our families we often form little
surrogate families Augustine himself by
the way tried doing that if you read the
confessions with some of his own friends
then if we go further out we have the
city or the state the political
organization and this might be something
quite small in terms of a Greek
city-state or you know a city in in
Switzerland or
something like that or it might be
something fairly extensive like say the
Roman Empire you know or the Persian
Empire or the Chinese Empire just to
name several the ones that were quite
important at that time or the kingdom of
Armenia all right buffer state between
the Persian and Roman empires and the
city or state affords is much greater
possibility of coordination there's all
sorts of other functions and tasks that
can come to to realize our human nature
but it's also subject to other problems
then extending further out from that we
can talk about the entire human race or
the world as well gassiness going to say
it the third circle is that of the world
and it includes
all human beings notice that Augustine
he might be willing to say that you know
the city or state could be tied in with
a particular ethnicity that is only one
of the levels and as a matter of fact
most of the cities and states at that
time were fairly multi-ethnic including
the Roman Empire but the world
definitely is so it incorporates peoples
of all different cultures and you know
ways of life and ways of thinking but
that's going to lead to problems as well
and then we have an even further circle
that of for the ancient pagans the gods
or as long as Tina's going to stay
within a Christian framework the good
angels they would also be part of this
massive Commonwealth that we'd all be
part of so we go out from the circle of
the family to the city or state to the
world of human beings to incorporate the
divine or divinely created at least
right because angels are not themselves
divine why are there so many problems
why doesn't this realization of our
social nature automatically come about
well Augustine tells us he gives us I'll
just go through a few of the examples he
says
who can enumerate all the great
grievances with which human society it
bounds who can weigh them here how one
of the comic writers makes one of his
characters express the common feelings
of human beings I am married this is one
misery children are born to me their
additional cares he says what shall I
say of the miseries of love which
Terence also recounts slight suspicions
quarrels war today peace tomorrow is not
human life full of such things so within
the household we have disagreements we
have disappointments we have conflicts
we can have exploitative relationships
we can have long-standing grudges and
feuds running throughout an entire
household from generation to generation
and Augustine also talks about the fact
that our friends you know our family we
don't really choose that much although
you can say that spouses certainly do
choose each other but their children
don't you see each other nor do they
choose their parents and when you choose
a spouse of course you're choosing their
family as well and it may be tough to
get along with them but friends at least
can't we just pick though the right
friends well even in friendships there
are problems even between good people
that arise and they can cause us to
experience all sorts of miseries even
worse when we find a good friend we're
always worried that they're gonna get
sick or they're gonna die on us or
they're gonna have to go somewhere else
so we don't actually have a true
fulfillment of all the goods of our
social nature at the level of the family
or household don't get me wrong
Augustine is not saying be a hermit give
up your family and friends he's just
saying in this life you're not gonna
find your full happiness there so some
people might say well what about the
city or the state there's a greater
level of organization as Aristotle said
to us in the politics the family that's
for living the state that's for living
well is that really the case well
there's a greater possibility of
conflicts within the city or state with
your
fellow citizens and Augustine brings up
lawsuits he also talks about the nature
of the judge who has to engage in this
inquiry and often has to put people to
the torture to get the answers out of
them fear of civil wars and indeed civil
conflicts we're not fully at peace and
sometimes we're at war with each other
within the city or state we have to
worry about criminality we have to worry
about people telling you know our
neighbors that were horrible and and we
should be pushed off of our land or
prosecuted or any of those sorts of
things
what about though the world what if we
embrace a sort of cosmopolitanism of
Augustine brings up the fact that within
the larger world once we leave the
boundaries of our own city our own group
our own tribe we're faced with the
problem of the confusion of languages we
can't always know what somebody else is
saying they are alien to us no there's
one way to try to handle this which is
let's just make everybody speak the same
language and have the same way of life
associated with that language and he
talks about without calling it as such
imperialism this you know putatively
benevolent spread of one way of existing
for human beings across many different
peoples forcing them all into one large
Commonwealth this is in fact what Rome
did but Rome was only the latest in a
succession of peoples that had done that
sometimes more successfully sometimes
less successfully it certainly didn't
bring about peace Concord and the lack
of conflict between people however so we
find within the world all sorts of
possibilities for things going wrong and
some of these could affect these smaller
circles your city your family could be
devastated by a war that is being fought
over conquest or who will be in charge
or which language and way of life will
dominate so that won't even necessarily
give you what you want
finally he talks about philosophers who
wish to have the gods for our friends
which would include Plato which would
include Aristotle which would include
the Stoics and he said they rank the
friendship of the Holy Angels in the
fourth circle of society advancing from
the three circles of society on earth to
the entire universe to the cosmos and he
says embracing heaven itself he says
well we can rest secure that the good
angels are not actually going to screw
us over but the problem is we don't
really know them that well we're not
familiar with them as we are with human
beings so it's kind of tough to judge
and it's not even quite clear to us how
we would connect up with them and have
some sort of commerce with them and he
brings up then the fact that the the
Fallen Angels the bad angels again
remember this within a Christian context
could be deceiving us could be seducing
us and this is in fact what the early
Christians took the Greek gods and the
gods of other people to beat and be
fallen angels so you know when you think
that you're involving yourself with
Apollo or Zeus or whoever else it is
you're actually involving yourself with
some some others so he says that here we
go those people can be tempted or just
deceived there's great need of God's
mercy to preserve us from making friends
of demons in disguise while we fancy we
have good angels for our friends for the
astuteness and deceitfulness of these
wicked spirits has exceeded bars
equalled by their hurtfulness and he
says is this not a great misery of human
life that we are involved in such
ignorance as but for God's mercy makes
us apprai to these beings these demons
so he says it's very certain that the
philosophers of the godless City the
city of man who have maintained that the
gods were their friends have fallen prey
to the malignant demons who rule that
city so at each point we've got a
problem coming up now this is important
we've got these four circles we've got a
sort of you know theory of how in fact
our social nature can be realized but we
find that in this existence it's not
going to happen without some sort of
divine aid and it won't happen
completely within this existence so
Augustine once again is making the point
and making the argument in the City of
God that our true good is not to be
realized within the world within our
social nature as such but only within
that social nature placed into a larger
theological context
you